you know i didn't feel amazing at the
start of the game
it was a little sluggish but uh i got
warmed up pretty quickly so let's jump
in i played e4 teamwork played e5 and
timor had uh
beaten me in a pro chesley game a couple
of years back in the
in the rye lopez and
i i didn't want to repeat that i thought
he might have prepared against that rye
lopez given that that's my main line
um so i decided on on a whim to play the
bishops opening bishop c4 hikaru plays
this against me all the time it's very
very fashionable
and i would say it's it's it's not the
same as the italian
uh and the difference between this and
the italian is that white doesn't
develop the knights f3
and the reason that that can be
important is that uh white is four ideas
at various points in this line there are
there are drawbacks
and one of those drawbacks is is uh
evidenced by
timur in this game you'll see almost
straight away why
you play knight f3 in the first place
thank you hojo jordan
[Music]
knight f6 by timor d3 and one of the
upsides of of d3
over knight c3 is that black has this
truck that i've shown many times in the
speed run knight take c4 and d5
uh of course here what white is great h5
and that's a different theoretical line
but d3
skirts that entirely i play just one
game result knight c6 knight c3
that's completely right as there's
monkey so this is still very much theory
i'm gonna be checking a reference to
show you guys
whether this was theory at which point
the theory um
the theory sort of you know ended
uh let me just do one more thing i'm
going to add the reference
the reference tab so you guys can
basically see what i'm seeing
in regards to uh chessbase's reference
feature
which allows us to look up all the games
played through that 10 gifted subs holy
spokes
this is unbelievable ah this might be
this is just insane ladies and gentlemen
absolutely insane man the amount
gifted just one bomb after another
after another thank you guys
huh amazing stuff all right
well what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to
all right we're good so basically you
guys can see i've activated the
reference feature thank you so much
mustachiola
you won all right guys
so you can see that this is a very
topical line thousands of games and
timor played knight a5 which is the main
move
uh which is a very simple move you're
trying to eliminate the bishop
white can't prevent that from happening
but that's part of the plan and here i
want i go knight g2 which is the main
move
now a lot of people looking at this who
have not played this line
uh would i imagine be a little bit
surprised 500 bits from dw0124
at the fact that i'm allowing black to
[ __ ] my pawns on the on the queen
side
why don't i like i i love it ladder and
never never said that
um of course i did yokta the prime and
100 bits from the backup
and essentially i i've talked about this
several times in in the speed run among
other
things um the fact that the pawns are
double does not tell
the whole story and what you should be
paying attention to here
thank you mean sweet bean for the prime
is the fact that white has this
clamp going on the d5 square
and that is a very important clamp
because white essentially has superior
central control here this structure to
me
uh is actually quite unpleasant for
black the computer often thinks this is
equal sorry
computer often thinks this is equal i
feel like white has the more pleasant
play here because it's very very hard
for black to
ever institute uh orchestrate the d5
pawn break right
so teamwork holds off on that he goes c6
let's check whether this is the main
line
uh this is not the main line i take c4
you can see is more popular but look at
the
white score is 52 by the way the chess
base when it gives you the score it's
always from white's perspective
uh 52 and c6 scores very very well
uh it scores over 50 for black
now i decided to go bishop b3 which is
very rare and
this shows you that i don't really know
the theory of this line very well so i
played a move that's only been played
five times
i was played by some decent players why
did i go bishop e3 well my
rationale was that if i were to castle
immediately
i was a little bit concerned that d5
would come with tempo it would come by
attacking the bishop although clearly as
the theory evidence is
this is not an issue uh and the reason
this is not an issue
is probably because black is unable to
hold together
his cent his center white immediately
starts attacking the center
and white's pieces just come out really
quickly and and i guess black is not
holding stuff holding stuff together
uh so this just shows you why it pays to
like actually know an opening
uh let me remove this yeah so this is
where we basically exited
out of the theory so i go bishop b3 i
don't think this is a big mistake i
think that
maybe it's just a little bit inaccurate
and timor goes bishop
to c5 now
obviously he can now take on b3 and
i can no longer get that structure i was
talking about thank you rob bell hingham
for the prime but i play a takes b3 i
still have double pawns
now i have nice control over the a file
i have pressure on the a file
and i thought that this structure i've
analyzed it before a little bit was
also quite interesting and and very much
combative
it's 90 plus 30 gaming 90 plus 30 second
increment per move so classical time
control
teamwork develops this bishop castle
castle castles castles captures captures
and
now pause the video and try to find the
move a bishop a bush hg5 here
and uh he simply resigned the game uh
and each gary over the draw
okay and i will take a sip of my water
okay so so far we've just been basically
developing our pieces nothing to write
home about
h6 bishop h4 is frequently thrown in in
these positions
and teamwork took a long time here i i
would say almost 15 minutes
uh because this pin is super annoying
and
white has two main plans in this
position
and he can combine them he can orchest
he can orchestrate only one of them
and there and they're very classical the
first is to prepare the f4 pun break
you can't do that immediately because of
the pin but you couldn't prepare it
what is the second plan absolutely our
money is very very talented what is the
oh pork ribs
is in here oh no no i thought i thought
pork ups was here what is the second
plan
and uh yeah he took exactly 15 minutes
the second idea or i wouldn't even say
plan it's more of an idea
it's in the same spirit as f4
uh not knight f5 well because knight g3
will get the bishop trapped
it's in the same spirit it's in the same
spirit as f4 it's in the center
you can try to play d4 yep a crucial
supper you're correct you can try to
play f4 you can try to play d4
and depending on where my opponent would
place his pieces
my intention was to try to decide which
of these two
pawn breaks to to play first or whether
to play both of them that's what i ended
up doing
timur goes bishop e7 he got fed up with
the pin
and i guess if black just played
something like d6
i was uh seriously considering playing
d4 and here's the problem
how do you evaluate pins what you need
to understand here is that black
actually has a very hard time
getting rid of the pin without ruining
his position if he moves his queen
i take on r6 that's unthinkable he has
to ruin his pawn structure if he doesn't
move his queen and plays g5
that also creates a massive pawn hook
which i can essentially exploit with
this
familiar f4 pawn break we've seen me do
this i think even on the speed run
several times so teamwork decides okay
not for the pin i'm gonna go bishop p7
i'm checking to see yeah at this point
oh there's still a game 2019
to 2200 bday2600
in this position there's only one game
and here i played a move that's never
been played before
i decided to play d4 now the reason i
didn't play f4
uh who can tell me why why f4 is
inferior
who can detect a very important subtlety
in this position why did i not play four
yeah exactly georbinky he takes f4 was
what i didn't like
and no matter what i take back with he's
got g5 and this is a fork
i thought about sacking the piece you
guys know me i will always think about
zack and the piece didn't
didn't find a good way to do it i don't
know enough pieces on the king's side
so i rejected this of course i can first
take on f6 but i didn't want to give
away this bishop this bishop is kind of
important
it's not about weakening the king side
remember that you can't make that
omelette without breaking the eggs
sometimes you do have to weaken the
king's side in order to start the attack
so i played d4
i played d4 t-more goes d6 now he
doesn't want to yields control of the
center and dominique mars in there
he doesn't want to yield control of the
center he takes d4 i thought queen d4
and i've got ideas of going e5 there's
no need for black to allow this so he
goes d6 as expected
um and at this point i played a move
which
i didn't hesitate over too much i go
queen d3
crumby cheesecake thank you for the six
months appreciate your support
those hundred sub bums coming into play
here so queen to d3 why did i make this
move
a couple of reasons number one i connect
the rooks
and prepare potentially to get a rook to
d1 which is the critical file
uh why take on d4 queen overnight uh
knight takes d4 is also possible i i
think both moves are okay
and well that's basically it i'm
connecting the rooks preparing rook t1 i
thought the queen is better placed here
and it's also supporting the e4 pawn one
thing that kind of annoyed me about this
position
one thing that kind of annoyed me about
this position is that black has this
constant tactical idea of knight takes
e4 which is quite typical in these posit
in these positions and then you get this
messy exchange
of moves now at the end i can take the
knight but i didn't want to have to deal
with this on every move
so i decided to eliminate it by playing
queen to d3 and timor here thought for a
long time
and he came up with a move b5 which i
think is a very sensible move he's
beginning the queen side pressure
um and we're beginning to to the
contours of the game are beginning to
slowly
materialize black is attacking on the
queen side i'm attacking in the center
and on the queen side
heaven asks why not take the bishop
because i i think that bishop's not
going anywhere
i i can't move the bishop so taking it
would put black's cards on the table
and in addition as we've discussed
taking the bishop kind of gets me the a
file and there are certain ideas
connected with
uh connected with keeping the bishop on
the board if that makes sense it's just
i would say by and large more flexible
and now i thought for a while i think 15
minutes
and can you explain the certain night
well i think i think that's what i'm
doing uh cj storm using a subs of psycho
thank you no i thought b4 was very
strong actually
so maybe i'm wrong but i thought it was
the only way for black to like gets
you know get the engine started on the
queen side so what specifically does
black want
by playing b5 well there's a couple of
things right b4
attacking the knight potentially that
bishop can come out to a6 if the square
is defended uh so i think it's a very
sensible move you see it often in these
types of positions and
here i was trying to make a decision
and i kept agonizing back and forth back
and forth back and forth
now the sort of russian old man you know
a very
simple move is rook
very stereotypical move so i thought
rook 81 for a long time i was going to
play but then i came up with a very
nasty idea that my opponent could have
um
could have implemented which is a6
and a6 and nasty don't seem to belong in
the same sentence together but if you
look very carefully at this position
does anybody see what black is
threatening if it were black's move here
what sequence of moves
is going to cause a lot of trouble to me
yeah joe binky is on fire so
you can take on d4 first although you
don't have to but this is even stronger
and now kind of a version of the noah's
ark trap c5 attacking the knight and if
the knight moves you go c4 attacking
the bishop and forking the queen but
even if it wasn't a fork the bishop
would be trapped by the way we had a
question about why keep the bishop on
the board
well that's one of the reasons why the
reason a6 is necessary is because if the
pawn was on a7 here
white would be able to capture b5
correct so does that make sense
uh and this is the reason why i rejected
rookie d1 i didn't see a good defense
against this now i can take on e5
and i can trade the queens but again you
guys know me
i didn't really want this i felt like it
was an equal end game black would have
no trouble making a draw here
i wanted to win particularly in light of
yesterday's game
and so i settled on another move which
is incredibly risky it's very sharp
and it leads to complete chaos which are
all three of those things i really like
and that is the move f4
i've talked about this before the move
itself should not be a surprise to
anybody i'm striking in the center i'm
essentially forcing the pawn on e5 to do
something because i'm attacking it i'm
threatening to capture it
with my f and d pawns and cause a lot of
problems
so the difference between this scenario
and the previous scenario
is a relatively subtle one now
previously if you guys remember why
didn't i play f4 on move 10
it was because of e takes f4 and g5
why can't he do that here uh great
question and i'll give you two reasons
first of all
in this line i've i thought of an
interesting
idea that i had which i didn't fully
calculate and that is the move queen to
g3
pinning the pawn to the king
now that doesn't seem like a problem you
guys might be like well wait a second he
just moves his king what's the what's
the what's the issue but now i can
sacrifice the bishop for two pawns
and in contrast to the previous case i
think now white has very serious
attacking chances on the king side right
i've got all these pieces and i've got
two pawns for the piece that's one idea
the more tame solution is to take on f6
and to take on f4 and in contrast to
the same me doing the same thing uh
here i already have a pawn on t4 and i
already have a queen centralized on d3
so i think that this is a noticeably
improved version thank you hof nba
gifting to the islands but appreciate it
uh and this method i call this well it's
not that i call it that the method of
comparison
my one of my first coaches had always
talked about that it's
it actually gives you a tremendous
amount of information about the position
to compare
two different lines and to detect the
differences to understand
what you know what makes one line
different from another and these subtle
differences
are really what it consists of at a
grand master level it's
it's not rocket science i'm i'm doing
this comparison during the game it's
just that the
actual differences themselves are are
relatively subtle it's not like one wins
one loses
it's just one is marginally better than
another so that's the reason why i
wasn't afraid of this mode
or the two reasons uh timor takes the
other pawn he takes d4
and now i take it with the knight now if
i took with the queen
that walks right into the noah's ark
trap c5 followed by c4 traps the bishop
okay i hope this is making sense so far
i play knight takes d4
and this is where things get super fun
basically from now until the end of the
game
now timor makes a very sensible move to
start he plays b
b4 uh which is a logical follow-up to
the move b5 he attacks the knight and
he opens up the diagonal which i
mentioned on a6 and he cannot put a
bishop on a6 right now that square is
protected
but if that square will somehow be
protected by
another piece then bishop a6 might win
an exchange and please stop me if i'm
going too fast or if i'm not making
sense i won't be offended
i i want every move to make perfect
sense
to as many people as possible so don't
be shy but ask me to repeat
you know to repeat my my thinking
process or to clarify
any details okay
now you're failing your essay okay of
course i have to go relatively fast i
can't spend 10 minutes on every move
okay i'll go a little bit slower i'll go
a little bit slower
so b4 attacking the knight and opening
up
opening up the diagonal i know there
will be people who think i'm going too
slow
so c5 immediately as i've
explained uh knight d takes b5 that's
the key right that's why he had to play
a6
in this position in order to support the
pawn
okay okay i appreciate it guys i i think
i i understand
uh i'm feeling the crowd gallantly thank
you for the prime
i can't satisfy everybody but i'll try
my best and uh he plays v4 now where
does my knight go
this is actually an interesting moment i
played knight a4
i think a lot of people would be very
surprised at this move because knights
on the rim are grim why am i voluntarily
putting it on the side
but there was a very concrete reason for
for this move
and i wanted to i want to emphasize that
at my level
uh you know in the speed run i'm often
using
logic and general principles to make
decisions i'm doing that here too
but that is always superseded by uh
concrete considerations like there's
just stuff that sometimes you have to
prevent and in order to prevent it
you have to make a move that violates a
certain general principle
and that is exactly the case here now if
i keep my knight in the center
um i was very worried about several
things but most of all i was worried
about the move queen b6
which not only creates this very nasty
pin
but what else is being prepared if you
guys
have been attentive to the ideas i was
mentioning
it will not take you long to see that
bishop a6 is a very nasty thread it
doesn't pin the queen to the rook but it
creates another pen white's position can
collapse
okay so that was one idea that i wanted
to prevent
and there was another idea which is a
lot deeper than that
and i'll explain that one too but to
understand the secondary idea of putting
that na4 you have to see how the game
continued
so let's look at timor's move which was
c 6 to c5 of course queen to b6 here is
no longer possible that would well it is
it's a boat says gambit
it would actually prepare bishop a6 but
it would come at a little bit too high
of a cost i would say
okay so teamwork goes c5 he continues
the pressure on the queen side he
attacks my other knight
and the knight has to move so i move it
back to f3 there's no other more active
squares to move it to if i want an ip5
the knight gets trapped i will bishop a6
is possible but a6 is even nastier the
knight has no squares
knight f5 looks good but he can just
take that knight
and i really want my pawn to be on e4 so
that i could thrust it to e5
and that basically leaves this square as
the only logical square
why not c6 because that square is also
protected by blacks knight which is on
a5
that's another reason he didn't take the
bishop
if timur had taken the bishop i would
have immediately taken on c6 and
counter-attacked the queen
that's why he kept that knight on a5
it's actually the glue piece
and here teamwork thought for 20 plus
minutes uh this was
i would say a game defining moment not
the only game defining moment but a game
defining moment
uh he actually sacrifices a pawn but he
has a very very deep idea
in store but before i talk about that
let me explain the secondary reason why
i put the knight on e4
let's say the black play is a neutral
move let's say that black plays some
sort of a
plain vanilla development move such
as bishop g4 just developing a piece
okay
my idea was going to be or actually
let's say bishop b7 that's more logical
i would have played the move e 4 to e5
striking in the center that was
always my main idea and let's trace what
happens here so d takes c5 f takes e5
attacking the knight using the fact that
my bishop is very strong here
now let's say that he moves his knight
out of the way to d5
okay which is probably not the best move
but i'm trying to give you guys a sense
for the idea not
sort of the specifics bishop takes
bishop
now if he takes with the queen he
relinquishes his control over the knight
to attackers one defender
i can take the knight that's a free
piece he's got to take the knight
now i can start by taking the queen here
to clear the cobwebs
and what is the final move what is the
final move of this
sequence could somebody tell me and this
will show you guys why
i put the knight on a4 the secondary
reason why i put the knight on a4
it was knight takes c5 that is a free
pawn and my knight gets back into the
game
so the secondary reason was that this
knight i anticipated would potentially
be able to capture the pawn on c5 which
would be weakened by
uh the central advance e5 so if that
knight was on e2 in this position i
would not have that equivalent move
all that for the drop of a pawn well
that comes back to what i explained
yesterday
uh aaron nimzovich said you know
good players are able to celebrate small
victories at this
level the game is decided oftentimes by
an accumulation of small factors
you know you might look at this and say
you know you you climbed everest for a
single pawn but to me a pawn is a very
very big deal
in a game between two grandmasters you
know that's like
you play a big basketball game nobody
screams at anybody for giving up an open
layup
but you know a famous basketball coach
like phil jackson
would scream at his defender for
allowing an open layup or an open
dunk that's a big deal to like a a coach
of a professional team it's the same
thing
well not the same thing but you get the
point um
uh this might not be game changing at
you know a 13 1400 level but it is
it is for me and my opponent okay
maybe in another stream i hold it up too
no that that wasn't very little i mean
that took me a while to figure out
it's not like i look at this and i see
it instantly okay
so anyways what does my opponent do
let's get to what he does beasty several
questions
queen c7 here was very interesting would
have prepared the move c4
and led to total chaos um
because i can go e5 and attack his
knight he can go c4 and attack my bishop
this is less interesting to people
uh because it's very chaotic i myself
didn't calculate fully the ramifications
of this
i can sack my queen here potentially for
two pieces but suffice it to say
this would have led to very very chaotic
position i think queen c7 was his best
move actually
timur goes c4 immediately and
when you guys are calculating a move
like this don't forget to count the
defenders and the attackers
if there's more defenders than attackers
on a square that means
you can capture whatever pawn has gone
to that square there's two
defenders and one attacker so this is
not actually
a four this doesn't win the queen and
the bishop
of course timor saw this he sacrifices
upon i'll show you guys the idea of this
um one moment
nothing okay
nothing happened um into the lessons
with charlie in fact
i've got some news that i'll share after
this game but i'm holding off on them
for now
but um we will be having a lesson
soon most probably
this weekend yes
um that's that's the news but i still
have to be
yeah i will be attending pog university
i'll still ha you know i have to do the
exact schedule but charlie has confirmed
it as of i
so we simply have to choose the day and
the time i'll announce it
um yes okay but let's move on with the
game i will be
making further announcements charlie
already gave it away yeah
i'll be well i already gave it away too
but um i wanted to make sure that it's
confirmed
i also want to make sure charlie knows
that i'm not in a position where i'm
like expecting him to get back into
chess
i'm i'm honored at every session with
him so
uh you know it's it's it's not like that
and
i know he knows that but he's he's very
nice so he
i feel like he might uh not want to say
no or something like that i wanted to
make sure he knows that that's not the
case with me
the lessons were not just for the pog
champs i think that's the point uh why
people enjoyed them
uh it was not in order to do something
but let's go back to the game
because we've got some fun stuff to
analyze so c4 by timor so bishop takes
c4 knight c4 queen c4
now there's two key observations
to make um there's two key observations
to make here
the first is that this knight on a4 has
lost guys let's let's uh
i know everybody's excited i am too
let's refocus on the game please
thank you so basically the knight on a4
is undefended
second of all this queen and this rook
are now on the same
diagonal there's no longer a
you know there's no longer a buffer and
teamwork finds a way
to threaten both things at the same time
who can see the move
queen to a5 is correct bingo
attacking the knight and threatening
bishop a6
takes f1 i had seen this move
when calculating knight a4 and i had
developed a response to it now the
problem is this if i go b3
and then bishop a6 it may appear that i
can defend both
both things at the same time with queen
to b3 but
bishop e6 is nasty and now my queen has
to has to leave and
i lose the contact with the knight and
that's something i've mentioned many
times the queen is the worst defender of
another piece because it's such a big
liability
you know that's like asking napoleon to
you know it's like asking some like uh i
don't even know what to compare it to um
somebody who's like fighting a war
um and you're asking like julius caesar
to clean a toilet on the front lines
right
somebody's gonna come around he's gonna
have to stop cleaning the toilet
clean the toilet is important but um i
hope nobody
you know i hope everybody's cleaning
their apartment regularly but
uh the queen has to leave and that's why
what something people don't understand
they think the queen is the strongest
piece
it is but it's also the worst defender
because it always has to move when it's
being attacked
okay perfect weapon and perfect target
which actually does make sense
yeah c4 then on poissant and i guess i
can defend the knight with this move but
okay this is just horrible
um well queen a3 already beer i won't
play d5
i'll play cb and your position collapses
okay
now i played the move e5 and this is
what i had cooked up
in preparation uh for calculating this
line
which is very sensible i am counter
attacking i'm counter-attacking
yeah so basically e5 what is the idea
i'm checking my phone yes
what a crime uh attacking f6 counter
attack of the night
now i i wanted to make the point okay
let's let's go
maybe not because anybody's misbehaving
but uh just
i i do want to you know i i usually
don't i'm not
like this but i want to stay focused on
the game when i'm analyzing it
because there's a lot going on i'm
putting a lot of effort into describing
the ideas
and i want to make sure that it it i'm
really invested in this making sense for
everybody otherwise it's not fun
for people if they're like lost so i
want to make sure that the chat is
promoting
that kind of discussion uh not trying to
be
pissy here but uh just you know i really
do want everybody to
have a good time during the analysis
okay um
so basically what is going on in this
position
i'm attacking the knight if he takes my
knight that's the simplest line
then i take his knight why is this a
problem thank you jimmy cecile for the
sub it's here one because if he takes
back the pawn
look at this pawn structure look at this
horrific pawn structure material is
even but obviously with a pawn structure
like this
and a king like this black's position is
horrific i can reposition my queen and
hunt for his pawn
this is very bad for black if he takes
the pawn
then i simply take back and the line
repeats itself
so essentially i am counterbalancing one
threat
with another threat but timor has seen
that and he sets
an e a third threat an est what i call
equal or stronger threat
both knights are being attacked but can
he attack my queen
yeah he still goes to a6 that hasn't
changed
so now after he takes f6 he can simply
take my queen bishop takes c4
so it's not about defending against the
threat it's about posing a stronger
threat
so i shift my queen back to b3 and
of course now the situation has slightly
changed
my knight is no longer attacked it's
defended
but what is attacked is my rook so what
is being attacked my rook and his knight
that's actually a good idea
keep in mind like what pieces are
hanging i know that sounds very banal
but when you're in a chaotic position
like this you want to always keep this
count this running counter
of what exactly is hanging so that you
can better make sense of the position
now he has a fundamental choice he can
take my rook or he can
move his knight if he moves his knight
to d5 and
simultaneously defends his bishop i have
a very strong move
rook ft1 posing a threat to his knight
thank you
nirvana for the tier 1 if he takes my
bishop who can tell me do i take back on
h4
or do i take on d5 who can tell me which
of these captures i should make
of course i should take the knight
because by taking the night i also
attack the queen and and then i'm gonna
win a piece here at or at the very least
one upon
but timor comes up with a very very uh
pretty idea actually
very pretty idea let me control z but i
accidentally deleted the uh rest of the
game there we go
he takes my rook this one i had missed
when i played knight a4 of course i had
now seen this idea when he played bishop
a6
but it was too late to double back not
that this is bad for me sorry
now this may look like a blunder to some
of you because i play e takes f6
right now i'm down in exchange but i'm
attacking both of his bishops at the
same time
if he moves one of them i take the other
if he plays bishop takes f6
i can take the other bishop and when we
finally when the smoke clears and we
take stock i have two pieces for a rook
two knights for a rook
that is an advantage for the two knights
particularly in a middle game
and all that remains for me is to
extricate this knight on a4 which i am
going to do
by trying to get it to c3 but i can't do
that yet but i'm going to try to
undermine that b4 pawn
so that that knight can finally fly back
home to c3
okay uh so that was going to be my idea
but timor has seen that
and he plays the move bishop b5 so he
decides to give up the other bishop
and he moves his rook away so what is he
doing don't i have two pieces for a
queen thank you mr llama well for pvm
thanks for the prime well he does
but my knight is trapped and not only is
my knight trapped
it was trapped before he's also
attacking it so i'm losing my knight
so right now i have an extra pawn and
two pieces for a rook which is a big
material advantage but i lose my night
uh that's not good but what is good
is the comp compensation that i have for
this exchange that i'm gonna be down
what what does that compensation consist
of
well first of all um
yeah mr lama i'll repeat the explanation
no problem so
basically the reason i played knight a4
rather than knight e2
there was a very simple reason and a
complicated reason the simple reason
the simple reason was that after 92
he could have played queen to b6 and
prepared this very nasty move bishop a6
the second reason more complicated
was that there was a particular
variation where that knight on a4 i'm
going to fast forward through it right
now
that knight on a4 could capture a
hanging pawn on c5
and i cut through some of the subtleties
but if the knight was on e2 here it
wouldn't have been able to capture there
right
jabba thing for the prime and drew cb so
sorry to
to go so fast there but i think you can
you can get the gist of it so
what are the compensatory factors here
for white number one is this e7 pawn
that's a pretty significant pawn oh it
doesn't threaten to promote anytime soon
but you guys can see how it holds back
black's pieces i mean black has to
assign at least one piece and probably
even more the task of
guarding the promotion square and in a
middle game like this that's a pretty
big deal
the second thing is well i do have a
pawn for the exchange which
lessens the sort of immediacy of the
material advantage and then the third
thing
is the fact that his pieces are kind of
clustered on the queen side
and i wanted to make sure that they stay
clustered on the queen side so i played
queen to d5 centralizing my own queen
and forcing his queen to take the knight
rather than his bishop his queen has to
go into like
this you know weird position on the
queen side where it's not participating
in a central fight now
don't confuse the purpose for playing
queen d5 i'm not really going after this
pawn
uh i did take it later that's a nice
byproduct of it but i don't take it
immediately because
that would have let us queen back into
the game with queen takes c2 so in these
positions
it's extremely important to make sure
all of your pieces are active
the game is often decided really by all
of your pieces being active 95 doesn't
work
if you play knight e5 with this idea he
can just take the queen and if you count
the pieces at the end of the line takes
takes takes
uh white is just down a queen furrow
because black takes that newly promoted
queen right
so is this making sense so far because
we're about to reach the moment
that you know where the magic happened
in agonized terms so knight d4
what is the purpose of this move
centralizing the knight then i can jump
to f5 later
and of course i am stopping his queen or
his rook from
reactivating itself by taking on c2 i'm
also attacking the bishop timor has to
move the bishop
and now i played a move that i'm
actually kind of proud of in the setup
eventually the winning idea i was
tempted to grab the pawn on d6 i was
very tempted to do that but i was
worried that he would bring his queen
back to d7
and i was very worried that he would
force a queen trade now you guys might
look at this and say well wait a second
why is a queen trade bad for white i
have two pawns for the exchange
um and the reason is that he's i think
going to win this pawn on e7 he's going
to play
f6 slicing off the bishop's contact with
the pawn king f7 and once he wins the
pun
white's going to be the one fighting for
a draw i felt like an endgame may look
good at the
on the surface but it's going to give
black a much easier time neutralizing my
initiative
why not pawn to b3 that's a good
question but i feel like that would have
actually helped him bring his queen back
into the game of queen d7 i considered
it
didn't like it i settled on a simple
logic i have one piece that's currently
not doing anything
which is not acceptable because i'm
already down in exchange i can't afford
redundancies like these so i go rook to
e1 whoops sorry not rook f1 rookie one
and ultimately the idea is twofold i
you know over protect the e7 pawn that's
important but more importantly
of course i have the idea of the rook
lift the rook lift being the most common
attacking idea
the rook lifts is only two moves away
and it's uh it's going to be very
dangerous if it appears on the board
yeah i considered that 5f6 that was
actually on my shortlist of
ideas f5 followed by f6 trying to
support the pawn
but i decided that this was a more
aggressive idea
so this is where the fun happens timor
goes rook a to b8
and his idea was to was to get this rook
away from
the contact that is currently made to it
by the queen
uh and his idea was to essentially free
up the other rook so that i could go to
c5 that was not
well that was actually a very
interesting idea uh nanuka asks
why can't he go bishop well then i take
the bishop the bishop is a key blockader
of the passer
and no matter what he takes with i'm
going to promote if he takes with a
queen i can promote immediately or i can
take his queen
and now he has not enough pieces
covering the promotion square
correct so can't do that he goes rook b8
i go rookie three now here he played a
move that surprised me timor played rook
c5 and i guess according to the computer
this was actually good this leads to the
fun complications we're at the
most fun part of the game so buckle up i
didn't expect rook c5 i thought the
reason he played rook b8
was to play this move b3 why
b3 what does this do well the idea
behind this move is actually very simple
he's trying to activate his queen
and he does it by intercepting white's
queen's control of the a2 pawn
if i take with the a pawn then the a
file is opened
he throws in a check and he captures the
pawn on b2
and the ultimate idea is that if i
complete my rook lift blindly
he captures on c2 and he gets a lot of
counter play against my king i actually
think
this is going to result in a perpetual
check queen c1 queen c2 at the very
least i didn't like how weak my king was
here
but i was worried about this and i was
going to play rookie one
doubling back forcing the queen onto b2
and then going c4
eliminating the idea of the sacrifice on
c2 and then i was going to slowly
re-prepare the rook lift or take on d6 i
think this was very complicated but i
think white's got the
practical advantage here so t murray i'm
i'm lifting my rook up to g3 the rook
left
being a very common tactical idea and
the idea behind the rook lift is that
i'm creating an x-ray against the king
that i'll be able to use to produce
various tactics against that king
since i accomplished the rook lift in
the game i'll be able to show some of
those tactics
okay timur goes work to c5 attacking my
queen i took the pawn
and he doubles rooks on c8 now his idea
was ultimately i think
to prepare a sacrifice on c2 which would
open up
my king and give him an artery to that
king and create counter play against my
my own king but i wasn't worried about
this i go rook to g3
okay this is this is the ultimate moment
in this position t-more played the
decisive mistake
which of course allowed me to put on the
board a beautiful combination
now why can't he take with a2 that's a
good question
the reason why is that he uh
would be giving up his rook and more
importantly if you look at this knight
it's guarding the c2 pawn so he doesn't
have that
avenue to get to my king my king is
still pretty safe
uh gem jim i think f5 f6 that was on my
short list that was my other candidate
move so i was deciding between f5 f6 and
rookie one
i actually think f5 might be even
stronger but i was a little bit
concerned
that he would get his queen back and
then he would lock up the position
and i actually wanted to reserve the f6
square for the bishop i'll show you why
later okay um so anyways he goes for bc
rook g3
now what did i expect during the game
during the game i expected the move
queen back to d7 i mentioned this idea
many times
he brings the queen back he he he
prepares the queen trade which is
unthinkable for white at this point i'm
so close to checkmate i really don't
want to trade queens
and so if i don't trade queens what do i
do because if i go queen takes h6 that's
the tempting move
he can't take the queen because of the
pin but what's the problem with this
move who sees it
well he just takes the knight with check
and that's not even the important part
the important part is that that queen
now guards against checkmate
and the more important part is that he
gets to me first
he gets to me first and i don't even
have to go on this is checkmate
uh in a couple of moves and that's the
that's the the brutal
truth about these positions it's we're
both at each other's throats
you take your foot off the gas pedal for
one second and you get demolished
so queen to f6 is the way to defend
against that so you have the same idea
it's not about taking the pawns here
it's not about taking the pawns here
it's about going
eyes on the prize going for the
checkmate he can't take my queen because
the pin he can't take my knight
because it's defended but that's not
even everything black has two ways to
defend against checkmate
number one is the move g6 sliding the
the pawn forward to a defended square
here i have let's say beautiful
combination number one but it's not even
really that beautiful
can anybody spell out this combination
white to play and give checkmate
sacrificing the rook paving open
the artery to black's king
king h7 it's not checkmate yet who sees
the crushing move
and the crushing move actually has two
ideas it's crucial to defend the knight
that knight is a big liability so you
play bishop f6 the bishop look at the
multitasking
defends the knight and sets up an
unstoppable checkmate
on one of these two squares so that
would not have
worked for my opponent but he has a
far more resilient idea and quite a
beautiful one
and i was reminded when i when i saw
this idea of a beautiful game that i saw
many years ago a
classic game where a combination like
this was played maybe i'll show it to
you guys afterward
uh and and it was eerily reminiscent of
it
um i i will show it to you one sec
and that is the move rook to g5
intercepting white's rook
and the king now if i play rook takes g5
you guys might be like well no problem
you know what what now well now he can
take the rook
and the legs have been cut off the
combination queen g5 queen d4 is just
over but even if he didn't have this
white's rook is an integral part of the
of the attack
um white rock is an integral part of the
attack so at first i i panicked but
then i discovered something very
beautiful and this leads to let's say
beautiful combination number two
this is a lot nicer i can take with the
bishop
i can take with the bishop what do you
mean you can take with the bishop you
you blundering the queen
but that's the whole point you sack the
queen burn my fingers tier one thank you
if you take the bishop by the way then
just rook takes g5 and black has not
achieved anything
so how does this line proceed bishop
takes f
sorry h g takes f6 bishop f6 the king
has only one square
and now a very typical attacking motif
rook g7 check
thank you parham big honor parham soodle
in the chat now i gotta analyze well
king to h8
now what's going on here obviously we
see
the uh the very typical attacking theme
the discovered check
and when we have a discover check
situation like this usually a windmill
wins the game the problem is there's no
windmill here
and the reason there is no windmill is
because i cannot capture my own pawn on
e7 i would have loved to do that but i
can't
the rook has no more squares along the
seventh rank i can go to any square
along the third rank but that doesn't
help
so at first it seems like it's a
perpetual but then i came up with a
really cool idea
how did i come up with it i discovered
in the course of my calculations
that i can give a check on f8 and the
freaking scoundrel of a king escapes via
g6 but
think backwards john bartholomew i think
calls this backward thinking in chess
can we solve that problem at the outset
of the king having that escape square
we can f5 f5
and now if it were white to move i would
give the check
and the check and this would be
checkmate because the king wouldn't have
this
exit anymore but that's not the end of
the line i discovered that black is a
defensive idea
black's only hypothetical defense here
would be to attack the bishop
if he attacks it with the queen notice
that by moving the rook i am again
multitasking
because that rook simultaneously defends
the bishop he can stave off checkmate
but he's down 800 pawns thank you
gigahertz gifting to parham
but what he can do is go rook c6 this is
insane
rook c6 attacks the bishop doesn't it
just blunder the rook what is the point
what is the point of rook c6 it's not to
just make one more random move
so there's two moves here that i
calculated queen d1 is the resilient
move if he plays queen takes f5
attacking the bishop from the other side
i give a check
and if you guys calculate this you're
like oh no i no longer have the pawn on
f5
crisis but um i don't think it is
because now the duties of the knight of
the pawn sorry
can be replaced with the knight 95 no
checks
again g6 discovered and this time he has
to give up his queen to stave off
checkmates that's one line
i was happy when i calculated this line
but then i saw that he can actually open
up the gates
rook c6 opens the gates and i started
calculating this
king f2 now there's only one question
here only one
can he or can he not um give perpetual
and actually looking at this later i
discovered that i had missed a couple of
key subtleties so i'm going to check
this with a computer afterward
what i had calculated during the game
was that he had two checks queen d2
queen c2 queen d2
i thought i escaped the checks king g3
check
king h4 and if he checks me on f4 who
can tell me what white does
rook g4 typical idea winning the queen
but in in post-mortem with david and
canty i discovered that queen f2 is a
far more resilient defense because
if rook g3 check that doesn't actually
win the queen and now the rook is pinned
this creates a whole host of problems
and um it's not easy to to escape the
checks if you go g3 you'll allow this
nasty check and that's out of the
question
if you go king g4 then sorry not eight
well actually h5 might be nasty too but
queen takes g2 is particularly nasty so
i'm not actually sure
whether black white is a way of avoiding
the checks here
um so i'll check that with the computer
afterward we can try to figure it out
but
i think nobody will blame me if i if i
put a pause there in this line now queen
takes c2 was the other move that i
realized
he had in postmortem which is and
the idea being he plays queen f5 and if
we compare this line to the
the other time that he played quite oh
my god i can still do it though
ha i can still go 95 amazing
and he still doesn't have any checks
this night simultaneously
defends against the two checks that he
may have and once again i go rook hey so
literally
he has this one resource and it might be
that
this resource saves black the game we'll
check
um amazing the best night ever look at
look at how heroically the night
multitask sorry my leg fell asleep
it's the only part of my body that is
asleep right now sorry about that
i know the camera is shaking so we'll
check
um but anyways um let's check right now
actually i'm gonna check with stockfish
let's see if this is in fact a draw
uh white white ones yes white winds
yes white winds i calculated this
correctly so basically
white does play white does play rook and
my computer might freeze up a little bit
here sorry i might have to turn this off
depth 200 sorry one second my computer
is freezing like super hardcore right
now
holy smokes jump jim taco
ah very simple oh my god what a vicious
plan
gem gym 10 thank you mr taco 10 gifted
appreciate it
rook g3 is the move and now very zen
knight d4 knight before
what is the idea defend f5 black has
only one check it's a meaningless one
because the king
finds solace on h3 sorry my leg fell
asleep it's like very uncomfortable
if black does nothing if black just
moves the bishop then you play knight f3
and then you play bishop d4 and the
ultimate idea is to dislodge
black's queen from the rook if black
moves away
then white gives the check on g7
and who can tell me how the game ends
because you have to make one very
important observation
about something that has happened in the
meantime
we've already seen the mating mechanism
but who wants to repeat it for me
well we haven't reached the part of the
game yet
check and now what can i do
check and checkmate now there's a pawn
on f5
this is checkmate okay
so this actually was winning and black's
only defense
according to the computer i think and
i'm gonna verify that with stockfish
later he had to find rook takes
c2 and this was insane because i i saw
this
and i thought that it wasn't dangerous i
thought i could play h3
and give myself a nice little escape
square on h2 but i guess
that queen b1 and rook c1 orchestrates
sufficient counterplay for black to make
a draw i will check that afterward
but this move i believe was the only
saving resource for black
but timor goes king h7 which is a very
sensible move
he simply removes this king from the pin
no problem you know remove the king from
the pan what's the what's the
what's the big issue and this is where i
found
probably you know one of my nicest
combinations
now most of you guys have seen this so i
won't keep this in suspense from
everybody
um it begins and i'll just talk about
how i saw this now
in such positions you follow the dictum
checks threats and captures right
so if you follow that principle and
you're optimistic which i am i always
want beautiful things to work so i
consider them
you look at rook takes g7 check that's a
pretty obvious move
in and of itself and after king takes g7
the obvious follow-up here the only
serious check because bishop f6 king h7
is uh is useless
that's right gem jam is queen f6 check
okay uh now the king has two escape
squares it cannot go to f8 it can go to
g8 and h7
if king h7 there's one very important
observation that i made at this point
which is that black does not have any
checks even if i were to make a quiet
move
i would have a tempo because black
doesn't have any checks threatened
why is that because of the queen on a4
remember all that time ago
when i played the move queen d5 to make
sure his queen was passable now he pays
the price for it now knight f5
threatening checkmate on g7 he's got no
direct defense
which means he has to take on f5 and um
i can take the rook here and win but
even better is to give a check on g4
and follow up with what move to finally
give checkmate
well that's awesome bishop f6
unstoppable made on g7
which means that he's got to play king
g8
and if you were to use the method of
comparison knight f5 is not effective
here
because this move is not a check but
here i found something
amazing and that is the move
knight to e6 sacrificing the knight i'm
two rooks down
for an exchange and now i sacrifice
another piece
threatening checkmate on g7 he has to
take the knight
but this opens up the passageway for the
queen to f8 drawing the king out
it's a similar concept to that uh knight
f5 line
bishop f6 threatening checkmate on g7
he played rook g5 which is useless
because that pawn on f4 is actually a
crucial cog in the machine
it stops the rook from coming to g5
without it that rook would have been
able to come to the rescue but the
beautiful line happens after game g6
yeah this is amazing thank you and
here's the thing at first i panicked
when i was calculating this because if
queen g7 the king escapes
this is not just not winning it's lost
the king escapes
but now we draw back to the observation
that black is not threatening any checks
which means i have a tempo
and i use that tempo to play g4
stopping his king from the stopping his
to escape squares on h5 and f5
and i can pre-move checkmate on g7 two
rooks down
checkmate is unstoppable and uh it took
me
30 45 seconds to convince myself that i
was not hallucinating that in fact he
had no checks and that in fact he could
not protect the g7 square
this might actually be from a purely
aesthetic perspective
you know what elevates this combination
i think because otherwise
it's all com composed of simple themes
timor played rook g5 first that doesn't
substantively change anything i take the
rook
i go g4 and here team were very
graciously allowed me to deliver the
checkmate
he plays b3 and queen g7 is mate
uh and that's how the game ended and
thanks to timor for
allowing to demonstrate this on the
board uh but really the nice line of
course would have been
without rook g5 because that would have
kept both extra rooks on the board
king g6 g4 and uh this is
this is a position that definitely will
be featured in
you know my best games if i ever write a
book like that
so just to recap the combination rook g7
drawing the king out
creating the f6 square queen f6 96
sacking the knight now i'm two works
down queen of faye bishop f6
and if king g6 then g4 ends the game
because queen g7 mate is unstoppable
gary thank you so much
for the prime and that was my game
against seymour so it definitely feels
good
lucky that this worked fortunate that he
didn't find rook takes c2 he played very
well was very combative it could have
gone either way
but it is always pleasant to deliver a
combination like that of course
and that's why i play aggressively you
know once once in a once in a blue moon
you get a chance to do something like
this
and it's and it's always worth it uh
there's the flip side of that of course
but uh when something like this happens
it does feel
you know nothing rivals the feeling of
having played a combination like
this that's that's why i play chess so
anyways
i hope you guys followed the analysis i
hope it was it was reasonable
and i really appreciate people
appreciating you know the combination
everything makes it even more fun
okay so that was the game any questions
thank you charlotte chess center and i
will be announcing something briefly
that involves charlotte chess center
before i move to blitz jam jam five
gifted
i have two and a half out of four
tomorrow is a rest day three more rounds
left
i am tied for second place with
lenderman christopher you drew robert
hess
and he occupies currently clear first
with three out of four the real mr
parikh thank you for tier one
i will definitely upload this analysis
to youtube probably even
tomorrow um and uh deliberate another
sub with prime appreciate the support so
much
it is a lot of coffee but hey i can
drink coffee at any hour
okay if not then let me transition back
how are you sure well i calculated see
that's what calculation is
that's what calculation is it's the
bridging the gap between uh sensing
something and confirming that it's the
case
all right pieces are on the queen type
rougher ten
ten for preference get a raid for men
holy smokes this is
unbelievable level of fight proffer with
ten gifted thank you
and min with a rate of 51. perfect
timing
well if he moves his bishop he can't
move his bishop because of queen g7
thank you man
and thank you proffer welcome guys i
just finished analyzing today's 15 bucks
from bill bill also
oh it ain't stopping amazing stuff thank
you so much